et bien voilà vous êtes avec moi j'aime
pas ce qu'on va rejoindre bernard rapp à
cannes pour le spécial cannes
traditionnel avec monsieur mastroianni
bernard
et bien kahn qui met un coup
d'accélérateur ce week-end dans ce
palais des festivals dernier refuge en
cas de tempête avec coup sur coup deux
jolis succès hier soir c'est le film
français de jean pierre denis champ
d'honneur dont je vous ai parlé
et puis aujourd'hui le film du
soviétique nikita mikhalkov un film
néanmoins italien ce sont les yeux noirs
au tchernia avec dans le rôle principal
marcello mastroianni tout à fait
étonnant dans un rôle de séducteur
menteur très fantasque mais pas dans la
logique de ce sommet de sa boîte jusqu'à
dire que new line ce match
sabat ce cas
ça cause ça basque
ce match se battre alors votre
personnage vous les derniers commencent
est un menteur séducteur frontière
italienne
si vous parlez plus du territoire
nigérien aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
comme ça quelqu'un qui dit qu'un petit
peu trop de fantasy qui ont occupé par
famille qui n'est pas méchant il a des
générosités n'est pas capable de soleil
ou bien ils passent à côté de sa vie
quand même on annonçait qu'un peu de
fellini c'est ce risque là c'est pas
votre sentiment
ma quand je constate avec lui je dis
qu'il ya des choses qui nous a préféré
ne me serais pas dans les screen je
dirais dans la nature de la façon de
travailler
l'humour les rigolades
ça fait
danilo n'y a que leur approche fine
c'est vrai moi il a dit que même à
l'étranger il fera toujours un fils jett
en humour russe alors vous montez
pendant ton film faites nous un beau
mensonge là sur le festival de cannes
que je suis content d'être venu ici
voilà c'est un film très attachant et
surtout c'est un film très drôle
d'ailleurs le rire est à l'ordre du jour
de ce festival avec un autre film et
américain cette fois